Phil you attended an event recently
where you got to be on the red carpet
which is something that so many actors
producers screenwriters all you know
want maybe that's not the end result for
them what can you talk about that
experience red carpets are a mind trip
and you're not prepared for them until
you do them now the first few that you
do they're great because for the first
time in your li career you're on the
list and you come up and they're oh yes
of course of course you're right do it
right this way where here's a gift bag
we're so glad that you're here and then
something really insidious happens as
you do more and more you notice that
their list you're not on and you start
to want to be on those lists and so then
you're no longer happy with the list
that you're on our wait till they're
gone but the more that you do you begin
to realize there's a hierarchy and then
something insidious happens because
you're on some list but you're not
another list and you start to resent the
list that you're not on the other thing
that happens is a disassociation with
why you wanted to do this in the first
place because you get a sense of
importance and the sense of importance
comes from the little bit of celebrity
that you have and from people treating
you as if you are something that you
know you're not and and I I think that
this is one of the root causes for
addictive behaviors that actors have it
really plays with your mind when people
begin to treat you as if you're
something special when and this actually
happened to me when you have just passed
somebody's sleeping on a piece of
cardboard on the street 20 feet away
from where you're standing on a piece of
Industrial carpet that's called the red
carpet
and you're hearing people say one more
bill look this way one more over here
and you've completely forgotten about
that guy you never even thought about
him but if there was a camera there you
might use him as a prop you think you
would never become that person but I
remember that specific event when that
happened and there's a piece of video
online of me and someone else on the red
carpet to remind me forever that it
happened and I also remember the first
time I went to a red carpet and I was
not on the list how pissed I was and how
entitled i felt and i almost said the
words don't you know yeah
I don't know that red carpet culture is
a good thing at all for an actor I think
it really helps to break down your craft
you